administration du 20e siècle
avec la départementalisation en 1946 les
grands services de l'état vont renforcer
leur présence à la réunion pour loger
toutes ces administrations et
accueillaient leurs fonctionnaires il
faut construire des bureaux dans les
années 60 70
plusieurs communes inaugurent leur hôtel
de ville réalisée en moins l'an de
basalte celui de cilaos est précédé
d'une grande place publique
inaugurée en 1966 le teil de ville de
saint benoît est l'oeuvre de jean
hébrard
conçu tout en béton il affiche des
lignes résolument contemporaine
trop à l'étroit dans l'ancien hôtel de
ville les services municipaux de saint
denis des ménages quant à eux en 1972
dans une nouvelle mairie en forme de
pyramide constitué de deux bâtiments un
édifice circulaire abritant l'assemblée
et anima bhl de verre et de béton de
cinq étages pour les bureaux le palais
de la source accueille en 1979 les
services du conseil général à leurs
principales collectivités locales de la
rue dans les années 1980 on assiste au
transfert de compétences dans le cadre
des lois de décentralisation de nouveaux
bâtiments comme le rectorat et la cité
administrative de champfleury sont
érigés dans la partie est de saint-denis
plusieurs services de l'état dont ceux
des impôts et du trésor public
s'installe dans l'imposante construction
implantée le long d'un mike est on autre
symbole architectural de cette nouvelle
réorganisation administrative l'hôtel de
région bien qu'inspiré d'un palmier
il a été rapidement désigné sous le nom
évocateur de pyramide inversée